mes chers amis je crois que vous l'avez
compris ce matin dans les territoires
l'alternance est en marche et rien ne
l'arrêtera
aujourd'hui nous devons tous dire un
grand merci à nicolas sarkozy d'avoir
remis en marche la famille et de nous
avoir tous rassemblés aujourd'hui nous
sommes les républicains et les
républicains vont faire entendre leur
voix
partout dans les territoires vivent les
républicains
alors vous connaissez le slogan de la
coupe du monde de foot de 98 et un et
deux et trois zéro est allé municipal et
de les départementales et 3 en décembre
c'est bien il y en a qui suivent alors
vous avez vu ce matin tous les nouveaux
visages de la droite
vous avez vu ce matin les nouveaux
visages des républicains il incarne la
france que nous voulons porter il
incarne le message de renouveau que nous
voulons porter nous allons réparer les
dégâts que françois hollande a causé
dans les territoires aujourd'hui nous
avons une gauche qui est rejetée au
niveau du gouvernement et qui est
discrédité dans les régions parce que le
bilan des régions socialistes c'est zéro
vision et c'est 100% gabegie impôts
clientélisme et c'est ça que nous
refusons c'est ça que nous rejetons
réparant les dégâts de françois hollande
dans légion je compte sur vous je compte
sur vous pour nous aider alors il faut
fonder nos campagnes régionales sur des
valeurs sûres les valeurs des
républicains ce mot valeur il faut pas
en avoir peur
nos valeurs c'est l'autorité c'est la
liberté c'est la justice et la justice
c'est tout le contraire de l'assistanat
vous avez vu que j'ai déposé une
proposition de loi qui doit être
emblématique de ce que nous allons
défendre pendant ces régionales
une proposition de loi pour la tolérance
zéro pour la fraude dans les transports
pourquoi parce que la fraude dans les
transports ces 500 millions d'euros de
gâchis et un moment où on nous parle de
fermer des lignes de train à un moment
où la sncf cherche désespérément à se
moderniser
nous nous devons dire que la loi de la
république doit être respecté par tous
et que la fraude ne doit être tolérée
nulle pa ce sont ce genre de
propositions concrètes
ce genre de solutions concrètes que nous
apporterons dans les territoires et je
vous invite à signer tous cette pétition
pour la tolérance zéro contre la fraude
parce que ce sera l'un des fils rouges
de cette campagne nous nous ferons
respecter dans les territoires partout
la loi de la république parce que c'est
injuste la fraude parce que la fraude
c'est ceux qui sont en règle qui payent
pour ceux qui ne respectent pas la loi
alors nous allons vous proposer une
vision pour nos territoires nous allons
vous proposer des rêves pour nos régions
et nous vous demandons d'être tous
derrière nous dans ces combats
c'est la dernière étape avant la
présidentielle
si nous basculons les régions nous
basculerons la france
alors est ce que vous voulez
l'alternance et si vous voulez
l'alternance
il va falloir se lever il va falloir se
bouger
il va falloir se mobiliser il va falloir
se mettre en route pour décembre
il va falloir basculer une par une
toutes les régions de france et il n'y a
aucune région je vous le dis dans les
yeux
aucune région qui ne peut aujourd'hui
être conquise
je suis ici avec tous nos chefs de file
ils sont exceptionnels ils sont
vaillants ils partent la fleur au fusil
parce qu'ils savent que partout les
combats vont être très difficiles
la gauche va y mettre toute son énergie
le gouvernement va y mettre toute sa
démagogie mais vous serez là vous serez
à nos côtés et je vous le dit andré
malraux a dit les grands rêves
poussent les hommes aux grandes actions
alors ayons des grands gré des grands
rêves et agissant pour nos régions
chaque chambre